In the recent film starting Tom Holland,
Peter Parker cooks up his own webbing
in his high-school chemistry class.
Now, he could have made
it out of anything,
like fishing line or even steel,
and yet he chooses to
replicate spider silk.
Spider silk.
This kid is trusting his life
to a flimsy-looking strand
of arachnid goo.
But it turns out, if Peter's web
is anything like real spider silk,
then his web-slinging
antics are more realistic
than they might appear.
Now, spider silk doesn't
look very durable.
After all, a strand can
be as little as 1/40
the thickness of a human hair,
but, pound for pound,
it's stronger than steel.
So if you twisted spider
silk into a thread
that was 2 millimeters wide,
as thick as a strand of spaghetti,
it could support 900
pounds before breaking,
strong enough for a
polar bear to hang from.
So a scrawny kid, like
Spider-Man? He's got this.
Jim Kakalios: And that's just for a
2-millimeter-diameter webbing.
If he needs more, he just
makes it a little bit thicker,
and it could support even more weight.
Narrator: That's physicist Jim Kakalios,
the author of "The
Physics of Superheroes."
He says that the secret
to spider silk's strength
is its structure.
Real spider silk has two major components:
extremely rigid nanocrystals
that make the silk sturdy
and stretchy, elastic
polymers that make it pliable.
That combination of tough and flexible
makes the silk extremely hard to tear,
and, if you look at Peter's lab notes,
it looks like he tries to
mimic that same structure.
Kakalios: So, it looks like it
is a set of organic molecules
that he is using,
and he's trying to combine them in ways
to polymerize them, to basically
take these complex molecules
and link them together in longer chains
that would then presumably fold down
and develop these nanocrystals
and the elastic polymers.
Narrator: But Peter may
have gone one step further
and actually made one improvement
to his synthetic silk.
Kakalios: I think that, instead
of these little nanocrystals
of proteins that spiders use,
he might be using carbon nanotubes
to provide the strength and rigidity.
Narrator: Carbon nanotubes
are basically a sheet of carbon atoms
that's been rolled up into a tube.
And if Jim's right, Peter is
one smart high-school student,
because these tiny tubes
are actually some of
the strongest material
known to humans.
In fact, they're over 100
times as strong as steel.
And that's when they're microscopic.
So, a spaghetti-thin strand of this stuff,
like what we see in "Spider-Man"?
It could support far more
than just 900 pounds.
Kakalios: That would be able to support
over 40,000 pounds.
Narrator: Suddenly that ferry scene
doesn't seem so far-fetched,
especially since we have the technology
to make those nanotubes in real life.
Scientists at the University
of Cincinnati, for example,
have figured out how to grow
carbon nanotubes in a lab
and then spool them into threads.
Sadly, those threads
aren't meant for
skyscraper-swinging antics.
The researcher's goal
is a tad more practical.
Kakalios: If you could manufacture it
and make threads out of carbon nanotubes,
you could make lightweight clothing
that would be stronger than Kevlar.
Narrator: So, when you
really think about it,
the most unrealistic thing
about Peter Parker's homemade webbing
is that a high schooler
figured out how to make it
in his chem class.